που μεγάλωσες που γενλοιπόν υπάρχει μια εντονη θυμολογία και υπογράφουν πολύ συχνά πάρα πολύ ημενα
κοντζάι ναι μαι αν πράβο ότι με αποντζάκι και μου παντάενε με στα όσα μήτιανατσι
αυτόν των τρόπον απαπότεεπευτκιάναν από και λίγα πράγματα γενήθηκαν στηλευκωσί σε ηλικία δύα τών χωρίς
ανιγονίσμου ο γιώργος το αρναρίτης μοναχογιώς του κρίτων τονα ρίτη του γενικούς αγγεάτες κυπριακής δημοκρατίας
ημητέρα μετάνη εμιλία κονσταντυνίδου γεντέθηκες στην αφρική να μην ταπολυλογούμε παντρευτήκα αγαπηθήκα χωρίσαν και αφήσαντρία
παιδια χωρισμένα ο ένας αδελφός μου κρίτων στο σπίτιο του παφού μας και εγώ και
ο αδελφός μουνίκος στο σπίτι μας με την μητέρα μας ύσκολα παιδικά χρόνια από τα
δύο μέχρι τα δέστρα μου χρόνια μεγάλος μια ειπτιακής καταγωγής κυρία πνοματεαθυνάτα γιαδόρου που μίνεις
καιδίπλα από το διαμέρισμα μας αργότερα εμητέρα μο στα τέσαρα χρόνια νωρίστηκε και παντρεύτηκε ε
τον τάκι τον σαβεριάδη που εχε τος αβάροότι ου είχε τοτητάκτα και έτσι μετακομούμετακομίσαμε εγώ
και ο νίκος πανταχωρισμένοι από τον άλλο μας αδελφό και ζήσαμε μέχρι την τουρκικίνης βολή
στην απόχαστων εγώ φοφιτούσα στην χρησήακτή είχαν τρομεράβιόματα αυτά τα οκτώ χρόνια τα οποία ταχρησιμοποιόσα
μαθήματα μέσα στο βιβλίο μου έτι οτός ώστε ένα βοηθίσω άλλες οικογένειες είτε χωρισμένες είτει
προβληματικές τέτοιου τίπου να να να τους δείξω το δρόμο ναπως μπωσς είναι μια σωστή
διαπειδαγώγησε να σας πω έτσι κάκάποιον παιδιών έζησαν την ισβολή μέχρι την τελευταία μέρα θυμάεα